so today I'm going to do a demonstration
which in my opinion is designed for life
it's one of the most amazing experiments
that you could dream of and we're going
to take a really really reactive
compound we're going to look at
phosphorus and we're going to look at
one of the other types of phosphorus
it's white phosphorus it's a very very
strained molecule it's very energetic
there's four atoms of phosphorus bonded
together to form a pyramidal structure
or a tetrahedral structure which we know
is p4 now all of these bonds inside this
structure are very very very strained
they want to release energy really
really quickly so they want to react
with reactive things so we're going to
react it with oxygen to form from the
oxide p2o5 and we're going to do that
today in this flask so it's just a
simple round bottom flask that we filled
with oxygen now why have we thought it
with oxygen well we've done that because
we want to increase the concentration of
oxygen by removing the diluent gas which
is nitrogen because nitrogen doesn't
sustain combustion and will slow down
the reaction so what I want to do first
is I want to test that there's no
nitrogen in there so I'm going to do
that by repeating the first experiment
that I ever did in science which is to
relight a glowing spill so here we can
see it's a simple wooden spill which I'm
going to like now Neil's got a torch so
here's the torch so there we have our
lighted spill now then if I blow it out
you can see it still got some glowing
embers now if I put this into the
oxygen-rich atmosphere you should
relight and let's have a look
and now straight away you can see that
this bill does relight so we know that
there's not very much nitrogen that
faster we can probably do our reaction
with phosphorus in the quickest possible
way so here's the white phosphorus the
p4 and you'll notice it stored
underwater because it's really really
reactive if I take it out and I let it
warm up
give it some activation energy it'll
start to react with the oxygen in the
air around us okay now what I need to do
is take a small amount out dry it and
put it into our oxygen-rich atmosphere
and then just warm it up slightly to
give it that activation energy to start
the oxidation reaction so this is very
reactive material so I'm gonna be very
very careful with it so if I take the
top off and I select a small piece of
the phosphorous and I think this one
will be quite nice so just take off the
most of the water drop it into the flask
so now you can see the phosphorous
sitting inside the glass flask which is
purged with oxygen we've put it on a
small amount of sand just to raise it
off the bottom of the flask so Neil is
now warming up this copper rod which I'm
going to use just to heat the phosphorus
so that it starts to react giving us
that really quite nice
combustion or that exothermic reaction
with oxygen now we'll add a small amount
of energy to the phosphorus and then
we'll watch what happens
so instantaneously you can see that
fantastic oxidation reaction as the
phosphorus reacts with the molecular
oxygen in the vapor in the gas inside
the flask to produce the amazing oxide P
2 O 5 which is hygroscopic and reacts
with water now fortunately for us we
don't have to breathe it because it's
being drawn away up our extraction
flames up our extraction hood but you
can see that the flask is covered in
this really quite nice white crystalline
or powdered solid and this is actually
phosphorescence so this glows even more
[Music]
so we're oxidizing phosphorus before
with molecular oxygen to make P 2 O 5 or
phosphorus pentoxide
which is actually a hygroscopic it
reacts with water so we're going to
begin very careful that we don't breathe
it in because we've made all sorts of
phosphoric acids within our lungs which
is really quite damaging but this is
actually used to dry molecules to dry
solvents for instance for synthetic
chemistry so it's quite a useful
compound in itself